-Welcome to the show.
-God, that was so cool.
-I'm so happy you're here.
-Oh, my God, that was epic.
-Come on! Yes, that was epic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being on the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-Your show "Never Have I Ever,"
by the way,
is a giant, giant hit
on Netflix.
It was co-created by
Mindy Kaling.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-I just want to say, it hit
number 1 in over 50 countries,
so not too shabby right there.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-It's --
You're very, very funny.
And growing up,
were you always funny?
-I mean,
I'm the youngest sibling,
so I had, like,
the usual antics.
Yeah, younger-sibling energy.
Let's go. Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Obviously stole a lot of
my mom's clothes.
You know, try to show up,
be center of attention.
Definitely made all of
my brother's
birthday parties about me.
Everyone's always looking at
my brother, you know?
"Happy birthday.
Good job, Vishwaa."
And I'm looking directly
into the camera,
making faces like...
Why did I do that? I don't know.
-Yeah. But now you're
a big star of a comedy.
-Yeah, apparently.
-Yeah. And this was like the
first big gig for you, right?
-First job.
-First job?
-Yeah. I really wanted
a part-time job
when I was in high school,
but I did not have the time.
Depression naps took over,
so -- Yeah.
-Depression naps.
-Yes, exactly.
So, this is my first job.
-And then, yeah, this is --
Look at the young Maitreyi
right there.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Oh, you do not need to
say "Aww" to that.
-No, no.
-This dork?
-That might be the cutest photo
we've ever shown on
"The Tonight Show."
Come on!
-That's joy.
This girl has it together.
She has it together.
-She really does
have it together.
But now here you are.
You get in there, you go,
you're on -- Is Mindy --
Are you getting advice from
Mindy Kaling?
-Yes, yes.
My favorite thing, though,
is to try and convince people
that we're distantly related,
because then they feel awkward.
They're like, "Oh, yeah, because
you guys are both brown,
like, yeah, you guys have
got to be related."
And then they're like,
"Oh, yeah, that makes sense."
And I'm like, "No, no.
I just totally made that up."
-Yeah, totally made that up.
-Yeah.
But I love that your voice in
the show -- no spoilers --
but your voiceover is
the voice of John McEnroe.
-Yeah. Good old McEnroe.
-And that is genius, by the way.
Did Mindy think of -- I don't
know whoever thought of that.
-Well, John McEnroe
is really important to Mindy.
And I think it's, like,
a great match made in heaven.
-He's important to everyone.
-Yeah, I think
he's important to everyone.
He's important to me
now that I know who he is.
-You didn't at first?
-I didn't know.
I'm not a sports kind of gal.
-Oh, he's a legend.
-He's a legend. He is.
He is.
-A living legend.
He's unbelievable. And funny.
-I know him as a narrating
legend, not necessarily tennis.
And, actually, funny story.
On set, when I met him,
I was like,
"Hey, do you, like, still sport?
Like, do you sports?"
-Do you sports?
-Like, "Do you sports?"
You know? I don't know.
-Do you sports?
-Maybe he's, like, taking a
break. I don't know.
I'm just trying to make
conversation with friends.
-Yeah, of course, yes.
And, so, John McEnroe
is like, "Yeah."
-And he's like, "Yeah.
Yeah, I do."
And I'm like,
"Oh, cool, cool, cool, cool.
I don't really sport,
so, like, guess I can't relate."
-"I don't sport."
-I don't do sports.
-Yeah.
-And then I asked him
if he wanted to go to
crafty and get cookies,
and he said, "Yeah."
-Yeah. He's the best.
-So it was great.
-This is the third season here,
and then you've been renewed for
a fourth and final season.
-Yes, fourth and final.
-Congratulations on that.
That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Maitreyi Ramakrishnan in
"Never Have I Ever."
Take a look at this.
-So, you want to go to
dinner this weekend?
-Oh, yeah.
Like,
heat up your mom's leftovers
and play "Fortnite" in your
garage with Trent and Marcus?
Sure.
-Damn. Is that what
our dates are like?
-Mm-hmm.
-That sucks.
No, like a real date,
like romantic.
Have you ever been to CPK?
-CPK? A.K.A.
California Pizza Kitchen?
Only the preeminent fast-casual
pizza chain in the U.S.
Now, that's a date.
I wish I could go.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Eh? Eh?
-Maitreyi Ramakrishnan.
Season 3 of "Never Have I Ever"
begins streaming
this Friday on Netflix.
Please come back.
-Hell yeah.
-Love you, bud.